this video was supposed to be about the
nine best prompts that you could use
with Google's newly released Bard model
it's just
like problem every time I tried one of
these epic ideas gpt4 did it better I
really wanted to come out here and say
look you can use it for this or for this
as you'll see it just didn't work out
that way so instead reluctantly I had to
change the title now unfortunately it's
just a comparison showing how much
better gpt4 is compared to Bard a lot of
people wanted this comparison after my
last video used Bing for comparison this
one's going to use open ai's gpt4 but I
wasn't satisfied with just showing you
the problems with Bard I wanted to find
the explanation in the end I didn't find
one reason I found six as the why Bard
is so far behind and why Google is
losing the AI race let's get to the
comparison first one is coding and as
you can see Bard refuses to do coding
they actually mentioned this in the FAQ
that Bard won't do coding for you as it
says I'm designed solely to process and
generate text as you can see it's a
fairly basic coding Challenge and Bard
won't do it gpt4 had no such qualms and
the code worked first time of course I
did check it and it worked but this was
just a simple challenge to turn letters
into numbers next and even worse for
Bard it can't summarize PDFs this is
going to be such a common use case for
Bing using gpt4 by the way it didn't
admit that it couldn't summarize the PDF
it summarized a completely different PDF
and if you check the other drafts none
of them summarize the correct PDF of
course the gpd4 accessed via open AI
also can't do this because it can't
access the web it also picked a
completely different paper but our old
friend Bing could indeed read the PDF
and summarize it okay what about
summarization when I literally paste in
the text that I needed to summarize this
is surely the most obvious use case of a
language model imagine you want to
summarize a meeting via Google meets or
shorten an email thread in Gmail it has
to get this right I pasted in the same
New York Times article into Bard and GP
for and I am sad to say that Bard
fluffed its lines the link to the
article will be in the description but I
have read it carefully and it makes
numerous mistakes let me scroll down and
show you this erroneous summary first it
says the FED is expected to raise
interest rates but doesn't say by whom
second it starts chatting about Full
Employment and inflation not only is
full employment not mentioned in the
article at all it also gets both numbers
wrong the unemployment rate in America
isn't currently 3.8 and inflation isn't
at 7.9 I check these against the latest
data and you can check it yourself but
both are wrong Bard also keeps going on
tangents like stocks are typically
considered to be risky Investments than
bonds okay that's fine but why are you
teaching me Financial advice it was
supposed to be summarizing an article
honestly it was a pretty unusable
summary so bad that to be honest you'd
have been better off just not reading it
trust me I am not an open AI Fanboy but
its model is just better currently
notice how a summary it doesn't go on
tangents and it clarifies that it's
investors who think that there will be a
quarter point increase the five bullet
points are succinct and accurate this is
a pretty colossal loss for Bard what
about light content creation and idea
generation surely it could do well here
just something innocent like create
eight new YouTube video ideas with
titles and synopses on integrating
generative AI into retail if Bard can't
be used by analysts maybe it can be used
by content creators not really I mean
you make your own mind up but these
titles are pretty repetitive and Bland I
know I can't really complain because my
channel name is AI explained but these
titles are just unoriginal and the
synopsis lack detail I'll let you read
these but compare them to Gypsy 4's
outputs each title is different and the
ideas are much more explored and nuanced
okay fine what about email composition
and I have to say count me a skeptic on
this one I have never ever found that
any model let alone Bard can do a decent
job at this it's not always that the
emails are bad it's just that the time
it takes me to teach the model what I
want to say in my email I could have
just written the email I'm going to make
a prediction at this point I don't think
using language models to do emails is
going to become that common of course
feel free to quote me on this in a
year's time now you're probably thinking
I'm being harsh this is a perfectly fine
email I did leave a thumbs up it's just
that I would never use Bard for this
purpose and I would also never use gpt4
like I don't want it to make up all
these extra details about what I'm going
to discuss with John it's just too risky
to send an email that has any chance of
hallucinations I know you guys might
think that I really love Bing but it's
even worse here it claims that I've
added relevant data and graphs no I
haven't I never mentioned anything about
data and graphs now my boss thinks I'm
going to do data and graphs what are you
doing Bing and then you're going to say
why am I using creative mode well if we
use balance mode or precise mode we go
back to the bad problem it's an okay
email now but look at the length of it I
could have just written it out would
have been quicker to do the email than
the prompt I was beginning to lose hope
in Bard so I tried writing assistance I
picked a paragraph that someone I know
used for a personal statement to get
into University of course they were
happy for me to share it it's decently
written but could be improved
significantly I asked Bard rewrite this
paragraph with better English make it
original professional and impactful now
Bard did remove some of the errors but
it again went on a wild tangent trying
to sell a career in data science as if
we were some sort of recruiter now I'm
not going to be too harsh if you just
take the first paragraph it's okay GPT
4's output is better but still has some
problems now I think some of you are
going to laugh at what happened with
Bing it simply refused to do it twice I
pretty much had to trick Bing to get it
to rewrite this paragraph first it says
my mistake I can't give a response to
that right now I tried again it said hmm
let's try a different topic sorry about
that that finally I just asked the exact
same thing with different words I said
rephrase this text with smoother
language it seemed to like that and then
did the job I think it's the best output
but still has problems anyway this is
not a grammar lesson so let's move to
science and physics and Bard completely
flops it gets this fairly basic physics
question wrong so how can it be a tutor
for us for a student to effectively
learn from a tutor there has to be a
degree of trust that the tutor is
telling the truth gpt4 by the way gets
this one right I even asked Bard to come
up with a multiple choice quiz it
definitely came up with the quiz problem
is quite a few of the answers were wrong
I didn't check all of them but look at
number seven and number eight the
correct answer just isn't there gpt4
does a lot better with really
interesting questions in increasing
order of difficulty now it does have a
some slip UPS look at question four
there are two correct answers one is a
half one is five over ten but they both
simplify to the same thing gpt4 was also
able to give these explanations I do
think the day of AI tutoring is fast
approaching I just don't think it's
quite here yet and certainly not with
Bard I think the point is pretty much
proven now so let's move on to the
explanations why has Google fallen so
far behind first a lot of its top
researchers have left there were eight
co-authors at Google for the famous
attention is all you need paper on the
Transformer architecture that's amazing
right they pretty much invented
Transformers problem is now all but one
of the papers eight co-authors have left
one joined openai and others have
started their own companies some of
which I'll be covering in future videos
speaking of which if you're learning
anything from this video please don't
forget to leave a like and a comment
next potential reason is that they don't
seem to want to interfere with their
lucrative search model as the product
lead for bad said I just want to be very
clear Bard is not search if you haven't
seen my initial review of Bard which
pretty much proves that it's terrible at
search do check out after this video If
Bard is designed for search what is it
designed for as the article points out
they haven't really provided specific
use cases next are they worried about
safety and accelerationism or are they
looking to buy up a competitor to open
AI they invested over 300 million
dollars in anthropic the stated goal of
that company is to work on AI safety and
Alignment so is Google trying to be on
the right side of history and place all
of its bets on safe AI or are they
trying to do to anthropic what Microsoft
did to open AI itself I'll be following
this particular story quite closely over
the coming weeks and months next maybe
Google has better models that they
genuinely don't want to release because
they fear a PR backlash they had the
Imogen text to image model that was
better than Dali 2 and they didn't
release it Google said it was because
Imogen encoded harmful stereotypes and
representations I dug into the original
image and paper and it was indeed much
better than Dali 2. Google wasn't
bluffing they had a better model and
that wasn't the last time in January of
this year they released a paper on Muse
a text to image Transformer that was
better than both Imogen and darli 2. in
case anyone thinks they're lying here I
think is the proof The Muse model
outputs are on the right the image and
outputs were in the middle and open ai's
Dali 2 outputs are on the left strikes
me that Google's Muse is one of the
first models to get text right
mid-journey even mid Journey version 5
definitely can't do this so why didn't
Google release this well I read to the
end of the newspaper and they say this
it's well known that models like
mid-journey and Muse can be leveraged
for misinformation harassment and
various types of Social and cultural
biases due to these important
considerations we opt not to release
code or a public demo at this point in
time let me know what you think in the
comments but I think it's more than
possible that Google has a language
model that's far better than Bard and
even far better than Palm perhaps
leveraging deepmind's chinchilla model
and that they are genuinely keeping it
back and not publishing papers on it
because they worry about these kind of
considerations anyway I do have a final
theory about Bard and that theory is
that they might have been working on
what they regard to be more serious
models in December Google released this
paper on medpalm it's a language model
tailored to help in a medical setting
and if you think it's accuracy of 67.6
in answering medical questions was good
wait till we hear about the fact they've
now released medpalm 2. here is a
snippet of Google's presentation on
medpalm 2 released just a week ago today
we're announcing results from medpalm 2
our new and improved model
mad Palm 2 has reached 85 accuracy on
the medical exam Benchmark in research
this performance is on par with expert
test takers it far exceeds the passing
score and it's an 18 leap over our own
state of art results from medpalm
medpumm 2 also performed impressively on
Indian medical exams and it's the first
AI system to exceed the passing score on
those challenging questions but finally
what does this say about the near-term
future of Bard well the more users a
model gets the more data it gets and so
the more easily a model can be improved
as this Forbes article points out
Microsoft now has access to the valuable
training data that these products
generate which is a dangerous Prospect
for an incumbent like Google and it's
not like Google doesn't know this the
CEO of Google admitted that products
like this talking about Bard get better
the more people use them it's a virtuous
cycle but does that mean that it will be
a vicious cycle if everyone uses gpt4
instead of Bard with less data does that
mean there'll be less Improvement of
Google's model only time will tell and I
will be there to test it thank you very
much for watching and do have a
wonderful day